HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND WITH
THE ONES YOU LOVE.
♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
BIG, BREAKING POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENTS TO SHARE
SURROUNDING THE DEEP STATE.
THIS IS VERY DETAILED.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
I HAVE TO UNPEAL THE LAYERS
OF THIS ONION.
FIRST, I HAVE TO ADMIT THE
McCABE NEWS ON THE
DECLINATION OF PROSECUTION
IS FRUSTRATING ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE IG HAD IDENTIFIED
FOUR SEPARATE INCIDENTS OF
LACK OF CANDOR.
THAT MEANS LYING.
SEEMS AS I SAID LAST NIGHT
ONLY CONSERVATIVES THEY SEEM
TO GET PUNISHED FOR THAT IN
TODAY’S AMERICA.
NOW, WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS IS
THE SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL, CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
AND IT IS PLAYING OUT BEFORE
OUR VERY EYES.
WE NOW SEE THAT THE
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT, WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
UNEQUAL JUSTICE.
A LACK OF EQUAL APPLICATION
OF OUR LAWS, EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM
OPERATED BY A GROUP OF,
AGAIN, THE 1% LAWLESS,
VINDICTIVE, EVIL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS.
ALL OF THIS IS ON THE LINE
IN THIS COUNTRY AND IT
MATTERS HOW IT TURNS OUT.
WE HAVE REASON TONIGHT LET
YOUR HEARTS NOT BE TROUBLED.
WHY?
BECAUSE BIG MAJOR
CONSEQUENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
CLEARLY ARE ON THE HORIZON.
NOW, SO FAR, WE HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY VINDICATED ON
EVERYTHING WE HAVE REPORTED
TO YOU, THE MEDIA MOB, THREE
LONG YEARS OF LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
HOAXES AND SMEARS AND
SLANDER AND BESMIRCHMENT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IN BETWEEN.
PROPAGANDA.
TONIGHT, AT THIS HOUR, THERE
ARE STILL CAREER, UNELECTED
BREWER DEMOCRATS WHO HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HATE THAT
YOU ELECTED HIM, AND ARE ON
WHAT IS AN UNYIELDING
MISSION TO CONTINUE TO
DESTROY ANYONE AND EVERYONE
WHO SUPPORTS HIM.
AND THE EVENTS UNFOLDING
THIS WEEK REPRESENT THE
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU FOR THREE YEARS
ON THIS SHOW.
ROBERT MUELLER’S TRUMP
HATING MINIONS RECOMMENDED
FIRST-TIME OFFENDER ROGER
STONE GET NINE YEARS IN
PRISON.
NINE YEARS FOR A PROCESS
CRIME?
WHAT, OVER A FEW OVERBLOWN
LIES?
NONVIOLENT PROCESS CRIMES.
LYING TO COUNSEL.
WELL, THEY LIE EVERY DAY.
ADAM SCHIFF LIES ALMOST
EVERY WORD THAT COMES OUT OF
HIS MOUTH.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, BREAKING
TODAY.
WE LEARNED ANDREW McCABE
WILL FACE TO TRIAL NO
CHARGES NO NOTHING.
McCABE LIED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND WE PROVED THAT
FIRED BY THE DOJ FOR HIS
LYING AND THE DEPARTMENT’S
INSPECTOR GENERAL
RECOMMENDED HIM FOR FEDERAL
PROSECUTION WRITING, QUOTE:
McCABE LACKED CANDOR ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
THREE OF THOSE OCCASIONS
INVOLVED TESTIMONY UNDER
OATH.
THAT’S NOT ALL, McCABE
EVEN ADMITTED THAT HE LIED
TO THE FBI.
BUT ANDREW McCABE IS
FACING NO CHARGES
WHATSOEVER.
AND GET THIS:  LOOK AT YOUR
SCREEN, BECAUSE BREAKING
MOMENTS AGO FELLOW DEEP
STATE HACK LISA PAGE IS
CELEBRATING.
SHE POSTED THAT PICTURE ON
TWITTER HOLDING A GLASS OF
WINE CAPTIONED "CHEERS,
ANDY" KEEP IN MIND THIS SAME
CLASSLESS INDIVIDUAL WAS
FORCED TO RESIGN FROM THE
FBI IN DISGRACE AFTER
EXCHANGING DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF NASTY TEXT MESSAGES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, WITH PURE UGLY
POLITICAL BIAS WITH HER BEST
FRIEND PETER STRZOK.
YOU KNOW THE GUY WHO SAID I
CAN SMELL THEM FROM HERE.
THE SMELLY TRUMP SUPPORTING
WALMART SHOPPERS.
WHAT A GREAT PAIR THEY ARE.
APPARENTLY, IF YOU ARE A
TRUMP-HATING BUREAUCRAT OR A
DEMOCRAT, YOU CAN PURGER
YOURSELF OR LIE TO THE FBI
WITH ZERO CONSEQUENCES OR
CAN YOU.
COME TO THINK OF IT LOOK AT
YOUR SCREEN IF COMEY OR
HILLARY CLINTON OR QUID PRO
QUO OR ANY PROMINENT
DEMOCRAT OR DEEP STATE
OFFICIAL SEEMS AT THIS HOUR
BUT IT’S ABOUT TO CHANGE, I
THINK.
YOU CAN COMMIT A WHOLE HOST
OF POTENTIAL CRIMES AND NOT
EVEN FACE AN INDICTMENT.
BUT, IF YOU ARE ROGER STONE
OR PAUL MANAFORT, BY THE
WAY, NOT TAKING A HIGH
RANKING GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
AND YOU HAVE NO SUPPORT
WHATSOEVER, BUT IF YOU ARE
STONE AND YOU LIE TO
CONGRESS, THEY WANTS TO PUT
YOU AWAY FOR, OH, NINE
YEARS.
BY THE WAY, THE MEDIAN TIME
SPENT IN PRISON FOR RAPE IS
FOUR YEARS AND TWO MONTHS
MURDER JUST A LITTLE OVER 13
YEARS.
YEAH, THAT’S REAL.
BREAKING TONIGHT, THIS COULD
ALL BE CHANGING VERY SOON.
WE ARE NOW BEGINNING TO SEE
SOMETHING VERY LARGE UNFOLD
MOMENTS AGO ROGER STONE’S
ATTORNEYS HAVE FILED A
MOTION FOR A NEW TRIAL.
THAT IS A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT.
THAT SHOULD BE GRANTED.
AND BY THE WAY IT SHOULD BE
THE BEGINNING OF STONE’S
ULTIMATE VINDICATION.
WE HAVE MORE GOOD NEWS.
McCABE DISMISSAL IS
FRANKLY WHEN YOU REALLY LOOK
AT IT, IT’S A DECLINATION
PROSECUTED ON ONE SPECIFIC
ISSUE.
HERE IS MY READ BETWEEN THAT
JNSD GENERAL FLYNN NEWS
TODAY BECAUSE WE KNOW BARR
JUST INSTALLED OUTSIDE
COUNSEL TO LOOK INTO THE
GENERAL FLYNN CASE.
SO I’M READING THE TEA
LEAVES HERE AND MY SOURCES
CONFIRMING, THE SAME SOURCES
THAT I HAVE BEEN USING FOR
YOU IN GETTING THE STORY
RIGHT FOR THREE YEARS.
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR IS FOCUSED ON
SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER, MUCH
DEEPER, THAT WILL HAVE FAR
RANGING RAMIFICATIONS.
SERIOUS RAMIFICATIONS THAT
1% THAT ABUSED POWER.
THAT 1% INVOLVED IN THE
CORRUPTION.
THOSE DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS
WHO ABUSED THEIR POWER.
BECAUSE, AS WE SPEAK, THE
DURHAM-BARR CRIMINAL PROBE
IS UNDERWAY.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD BY MY
SOURCES THAT, IN FACT, IT
HAS GONE DEEP.
IT HAS GONE WIDE.
IT HAS GONE FAR.
AND THE EVIDENCE THEY ARE
ACCUMULATING IS OVERWHELMING
AND INCONTROVERTIBLE.
THAT’S WHAT MY SOURCES ARE
TELLING ME TONIGHT.
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE REFER TO
ALL OF OF THIS AS THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATORS.
NOW, ACCORDING TO REPORTS,
THIS INVESTIGATION
SCRUTINIZING THE ACTIONS NOW
AND WE HAVE BEEN WONDERING
WHEN THIS IS GOING TO COME.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN AND MANY OTHER
CURRENT AND FORMER DEEP
STATE OFFICIALS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE RUSSIA HOAX.
REMEMBER, THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA HOAX, THAT’S THE
HEART OF THE INVESTIGATION.
NOW IT’S EXPANDED OUT FAR
AND WIDE.
DURHAM HAS SPENT WEEKS IN
ITALY AND GREAT BRITAIN.
THAT WOULD TELL ME AND
INDICATE TO ME THAT THE
OUTSOURCING OF
INTELLIGENCE-GATHERING AND
SPYING ON AMERICANS TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAW IS
IN PLAY.
I’M TOLD THAT THIS EVIDENCE
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE WAS
ABOUT PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
A FISA COURT.
NOBODY ELSE IN THE MEDIA GOT
THAT STORY RIGHT.
WE GOT IT RIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM.
THE EVIDENCE IS PROVEN.
IT’S A SLAM DUNK CASE.
WE ALREADY HAVE THAT.
AND BARR HAS ALREADY
CONFIRMED -- YOU HAVE GOT TO
PAY ATTENTION -- THAT THE
FISA APPLICATIONS WERE
FRAUDULENT.
BARR HAS ALREADY CONFIRMED
THAT A CANDIDATE, DONALD
TRUMP, HIS TRANSITION TEAM
AND DEEP INTO THE PRESIDENCY
OF DONALD TRUMP SPYING
HAPPENED.
YES, HE USED THE WORD
SPYING.
OKAY.
NOW, WE KNOW ABOUT THE
WARNINGS.
MULTIPLE WARNINGS THAT WERE
GIVEN TO THOSE WHEN THEY
FILED THE FISA APPLICATIONS.
DON’T TRUST AGENDA.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT AND IT’S
NOT VERIFIED.
MULTIPLE WARNINGS.
THAT MEANS PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON THE COURT.  THAT
MEANS A HUGE DAY OF
RECKONING TO ME MAY BE ON
THE HORIZON.
I DON’T THINK I’M WRONG.
POTENTIAL CHARGES FOR SO
MANY WHO RECKLESSLY ABUSE
YOU HAD FINEST COURT OR ANY
OF THIS NATION’S POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE.
WE ENTRUST WITH YOU THOSE
TOOLS.
YOU DON’T GET TO TURN THEM
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A POLITICAL
AGENDA AND NEW DEVELOPMENT.
THAT’S NOT ALL.
WE LEARNED TODAY THAT BARR
ORDERED OUTSIDE PROSECUTORS
TO REVIEW THE CASE OF
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN.
THANK GOD.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER JAMES
COMEY BRAGGING ON CAMERA
ABOUT SETTING FLYNN UP AND
OH, I SENT MY GUYS IN THERE.
I WOULD NEVER DO THAT IN THE
TRUMP OR BUSH
ADMINISTRATIONS OR EVER GET
AWAY WITH IT.
DECORATED MILITARY HERO, 33
YEARS.
THEY FORCED OF HIM TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO ONE CHARGE LYING
TO INVESTIGATORS.
BUT THE INVESTIGATORS
ACTUALLY DIDN’T THINK HE WAS
LYING.
WHY DID HE DO IT?
THEY THREATENED TO GO AFTER
HIS FAMILY AND KID AND
COULDN’T SELL HIS HOUSE
BECAUSE THEY COULDN’T PAY
THE LAWYERS.
INITIAL REPORTS FLYNN DIDN’T
APPEAR TO BE LYING.
MADE HIM LIFE SO HE COULD
SAVE HIS SON.
WHAT FATHER WOULDN’T DO THAT
HERE IS HOW I INTERPRET THAT
ACTION.
GENERAL FLYNN WILL BE
VINDICATED CAN I BELIEVE
TONIGHT AND I HAVE TO
BELIEVE TONIGHT THAT THE
DURHAM-BARR PROBE WILL
DELIVER A DEVASTATING BLOW
TO THE DEEP STATE WHICH HAS
TO HAPPEN.
OR WE MIGHT AS WELL TAKE OUR
CONSTITUTION AND SPREAD IT.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
OR APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS
WILL BE DEAD.
THESE ARE CLEAR MESSAGES NOW
BEING SENT.
BARR STEPPED IN AND STOPPED
THE PROSECUTORIAL ABUSE ON
ROGER STONE, THAT WAS HUGE.
THAT CASE NEEDS TO BE
VACATED COMPLETELY AS WE NOW
KNOW THE JURY FOREPERSON HAD
A POLITICAL AGENDA OH, A
DEMOCRAT AN ACTIVIST
DEMOCRAT ACTUALLY EVEN
TALKED ABOUT THE CASE.
TO DATE, MY SOURCES HAVE
BEEN RIGHT THE ENTIRE TIME.
SO, TONIGHT, I IT REPORT
THIS, I’M CAUTIOUSLESS
OPTIMISTIC THAT REAL JUSTICE
WILL BE DONE.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE DECKS
ARE BEING CLEARED.
2 LOOKS LIKE A FIVE ALARM
FIRE HAPPENING AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE SHOULD KNOW IN SHORT
ORDER MEANING A FEW MONTHS,
WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
HOW THIS WILL FALL OUT.
TO HIS CREDIT THE PRESIDENT
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
YESTERDAY IS GIVING THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO CONDUCT
WHAT IS IMPORTANT,
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS.
IT IS COMPLETELY BY THE WAY
WITHIN THE PRESIDENT’S POWER
TO ORDER THE PROBE HIMSELF.
DID YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT
IS THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THE COUNTRY?
HE IS NUMBER ONE.
WHEN THE A.G. STEPPED IN TO
AMEND THE AGREED TO THE
SENTENCING OF ROGER STONE HE
DID THAT ON HIS OWN.
WHO HE DID WITH GENERAL
FLYNN HE DID ON HIS OWN.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND NEW
REPORT FROM KIMBERLEY
STRASSEL, "WALL STREET
JOURNAL," HERE IS WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, QUOTE:
AND HER SOURCES HAVE BEEN
IMPECCABLE.
ENTER U.S. ATTORNEY TIM SHAE
TOLD THE DEPARTMENT’S
LEADERSHIP HE AND OTHER CAR
OFFICIALS IN THE DEPARTMENT
FELT THE SENTENCE WAS
EXCESSIVE.
AS FOR THE DEAD LINE FOR THE
FILING AS THAT NEAR YOU HAD
THE PROSECUTORS ON THE CASE,
MONTHS, THREATENED TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE CASE
UNLESS THEY GOT THEIR
DEMANDS FOR THE STIFFEST
PENALTIES MET.
MR. SHAE, NEW TO THE JOB,
SUFFERED A MOMENT OF
COWARDICE AND SUBMITTED TO
THAT ULTIMATUM.
HIGH RANKING DOJ OFFICIALS
SAID TO DECIDE THESE THINGS,
THEY DECIDED TO REVERSE THE
SENTENCING WAY BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT ISSUED ANY TWEET
CONDEMNING IT.
BUT, FOUR OF THE TRUMP
HATING PRURTS HEPROSECUTORS AND
REVENGE AND ZELL ALSOLESS
AND OVERREACH AND ABUSE
RESIGNED IN A FIT OF ANGER
APPARENTLY.
AND AS STROSSEL POINTS OUT
THEY FAILED TO REALIZE THAT
CAREER CIVIL SERVANTS AREN’T
SOME ARISTOCRATIC CLASS
ENTITLED TO IMMUNITY.
THEY ARE EMPLOYEES.
THE DANGER ISN’T POLITICAL
AUTHORITY BUT RATHER
UNELECTED MAN DARREN CLASS
EXEMPT ITS 168 FROM
DEMOCRATIC ACCOUNTABILITY.
DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER GET THE
CHOICE COME IN.
THE WAY OF A GOOD OLD
FASHIONED WITCH-HUNT WILL
THEY.
CONGRESSMAN COLLINS OF
GEORGIA USINGTH STONE
SENTENCING FOR AN EXCUSE.
NOW THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
ANOTHER IMPEACHMENT PUSH.
AND YOU HAVE OF COURSE THE
COMPROMISE YOU HAD CORRUPTED
CONGENITAL LIAR AND COURT
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE IS FOAMING AT THE MOUTH.
ANOTHER WAY TO STOP A
SCHUMER SCHIFF SHAM SHOW.
ONLY ONE OTHER WAY I KNOW
263 DAYS ULTIMATE JURY.
SHOT CLOCK THE WORLD AGAIN.
IF YOU VOTE FOR THE PUT,
ELECT REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
MEN AND SENATORS THEY CAN’T
DO THIS ANYMORE.
THIS IS THE MOST CONSZ
SEQUENTIAL ELECTION,
FRANKLY, IN MODERN HISTORY.
AND I’M NOT OVERSTATING THE
CASE.
WE ARE NOW, AS A NATION AND
FRANKLY THE WORLD ARE ON THE
BRINK AND TODAY WE CAN’T BE
HELPFUL.
I CAN’T GIVE YOU A TIMELINE
INTO THE INVESTIGATION OF
THE INVESTIGATORS IT MOVES
SLOW BUT DRIVES ME TUTS.
THE NUTS.
THE DOJ STEP IN ON STONE,
THAT IS IS NOT A SMALL THING.
THE FOUR HACKS LEAVING THE
DOJ KNOT A SMALL THING.
THE REVIEW OF THE BEGIN CASE
IS NOT A SMALL CASE EITHER.
WEEKS AND WEEKS DUMP AND
BARR SENT ABROAD IS SENDS A
REAL SIGNAL THAT THEY WANT
TO GET TO THE OUTSOURCING OF
SPYING ON AMERICANS AND THAT
BRINGS IT RIGHT TO THE FRONT
DOOR OF JOHN BRENNAN.
WHAT DID HE KNOW AND WHEN
DID HE KNOW IT AND WHEN DID
OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN DID HE